bonjour et bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro deux parlements et bleu aux
compagnies cette semaine de delphine
gérard bon journal clean
nous voici ensemble pour 45 minutes
d'actualité politique et parlementaire
avec cette semaine le vrai faux retour
triomphal de nicolas sarkozy sur la
scène politique
arrivé à pied au siège de l'ump accueil
de rock star et un discours de 40
minutes devant les responsables et
parlementaires ump pour dire que le
moment n'est pas venu de son retour en
politique
le sarkothon comme certains l'appellent
aurait rapporté à ce jour plus de 3
millions d'euros contre à l'assemblée
nationale la discipline de groupe a
parfaitement fonctionné cette semaine
chez les socialistes le texte phare du
gouvernement sur l'interdiction du cumul
des mandats a été adopté à la majorité
absolue avec l'apport des voix
d'écologistes et cognis le gouvernement
voit donc aborder plus sereinement
l'épreuve du sénat sur ce texte
enfin les sénateurs qui décidément donne
du fil à retordre au gouvernement ils
ont retardé cette semaine l'examen du
texte sur la transparence de la vie
politique avec notamment une motion de
renvoi en commission présentée par les
radicaux de gauche qui décidément joue
les trublions de la majorité est avec
nous à cette semaine pour commenter à
les temps forts de l'actualité
parlementaire bruno le roux président du
groupe socialiste à l'assemblée
nationale merci d'être avec nous on va
dérouler ensemble on va dérouler
ensemble les temps forts de cette
semaine nous avons cela c'est la
tradition dans cette émission vous
propose d'écouter ce que pensent de vous
vos collègues députés morceaux choisis
je pense que c'est un excellent
président pour le vote socialiste
c'est un homme de conviction c'est un
homme d'autorité qui aussi est un homme
convivial et qui est cette banque amara
il n'est pas antipathique
il est à peu près moitié
il intervient avec le rappel au
règlement un peu à tort et à travers
mais cette bonne guerre il est là quand
il faut de sa grosse voix là qu'ils
forcent un peu comme si se croyait dans
un opéra pour sourds il développe ses
arguments toujours les mêmes c'est
presque un métier
il a ce côté jovial qui me fait penser
quelques fois au moins qui est sur la
boîte de camembert qui est là satisfait
du travail qui fait et qui peut créer
qu'un temps leur regard de une certaine
gourmandise
il a sans doute des qualités c'est
dommage qu'il ait cache autant et si les
de la rondeur la rondeur dans tous les
cas j'attends de la voir dans les propos
je ressens plutôt quelqu'un d'
extrêmement rigide parfois même crispé
et qui n'est pas suffisamment l écoute
c'est quelqu'un qui est capable à la
fois d'une grande rigueur d'equipe d'une
grande générosité individuelle
alors bruno le roux on a entendu un
aspect jovial mais peut-être disait
daniel fasquelle de la rigidité c'est la
fonction de président de groupe qui
impose sa très certainement un peu la
fonction c'est une fonction qui demande
de l'autorité je remarque que venant de
mes collègues du groupe les propos
étaient les propos très sympathique et
venant de l'opposition il était d'autant
plus sympathique que je connaissais bien
les députés pour avoir travaillé avec
eux sont des textes et et pour ne pas
simplement avoir une relation
d'hémicycle une relation lointaine je
pense que peut-être que monsieur
fasquelle a raison peut-être même que
monsieur collard même si avoir des
propos qu'il fit en main est ce que vous
avez senti que vous devenez plus rigide
est ce qu'il faut plus se tenir vos
troupes
à la question c'est pas la rigidité la
question c'est toujours de savoir
prendre les décisions et les faire
partager
c'est en ça que nous sommes attendus
prendre des décisions sur les
amendements sur la préparation des
textes sur le vote tel qu'il va
intervenir dans l'hémicycle est donc ce
que l'on me demande c'est de donner un
sens d'amener mon groupe à faire en
sorte de soutenir le mieux possible le
président de la république le premier
ministre et donc il faut pour cela
oui une certaine autorité mais avec de
l'autorité on ne réussit pas tout seul
qui sont dans mon groupe ont été élus
ils ont une présence sur le terrain ils
ont une visibilité et donc on les mène
pas à la baguette comme pourrait vouloir
le faire dans d'autres instances
d'autres personnes moi je suis dans
l'obligation et ça me va très bien
d'avoir de l'autorité mais d'écouter
alors de l'autorité est pas de rigidités
pour commenter avec nous l'actualité de
la semaine on en est sûr on commence
lundi bien sûr avec un fan club au siège
de l'ump
on en parlait depuis trois jours le
voilà enfin il arrive à pied acclamé par
les militants nicolas sarkozy vient
assister à une réunion de crise à l'ump
après l'invalidation de ses comptes de
campagne
ou plutôt responsables et parlementaires
viennent d'assister à son discours
pierre lascars il était attendu de pied
ferme par quelques dizaines de militants
devant les membres d'un bureau politique
élargi nicolas sarkozy est venu apporter
un message de solidarité alors que l'ump
traverse une mauvaise passe financière
dieu alain validation des comptes de
campagne très important
dans la foi de d'amitié de solidarité à
l'égard notre famille politique et vous
savez combien nous sommes les uns et les
autres est attaché à lui ça n'est pas
pour autant il a dit lui-même un retour
en politique
pas de retour en politique mais devant
l'état major de l'ump l'ancien chef de
l'état a passé en revue la situation
politique nationale
l'état de l'économie mondiale ou encore
la crise financière à la sortie tous les
cadres du mouvement en appelle à l'unité
l'unité derrière nicolas sarkozy
ah ben c'est la famille qui serait une
et vous savez quand il ya des problèmes
dans une famille il faut réunir toute
attaque
je crois tout le monde est solidaire
je crois qu'on va faire tous les efforts
nécessaires qui m'a marqué c'est à la
fois une fois de plus son attachement au
mouvement son attachement aux françaises
et aux français ce discours d'un homme
tué près de son parti dans celui ci a
versé des députés et là il a dit avec
beaucoup de simplicité et beaucoup de
force
il est avec ruag difficulté qu'on
traverse finale durant la réunion
nicolas sarkozy a également jugé qu'il
serait je cite indécent de penser à 2017
aujourd'hui xavier bertrand françois
fillon ou bruno le maire apprécieront
eux qui sont déjà tous trois candidats
aux primaires de l'ump pour 2010 est
nombreux dans l'euro vous regardez ça
avoue d'un petit peu loin évidemment
c'est un retour en politique que c'est
partout en politique je crois qu'il l'a
dit que ce n'était pas un retour mais
depuis il y a eu des propos il y avait
les propos par exemple de monsieur
fillon à la grande motte qui montre
enfin de compte trois jours plus tard
que pour de nombreux responsables
ce rendez-vous a été une épreuve ceux
qui n'ont pas suivi l'ump ne doit pas
rester congelés au garde à vous dans la
tente de l'homme providentiel de sueur
et on voit bien qu'ils étaient tous
rassemblés parce que ils savent eux se
rassembler en ce moment là et que pour
autant il n'accordait pas la même
signification à ce retour ce vrai faux
retour de monsieur sarkozy qu'il faut
d'ailleurs regardé parce que on acclame
mais ce jour là quelqu'un qui avait été
condamné pour fraude
parce que c'est bien cela qui s'est
passé par le conseil constitutionnel
il y à une fausse déclaration de l'ump
du président de la république il y a eu
donc une condamnation et la condamnation
de campagne mais dépassement des comptes
de campagne mais cela paie valu à
quelques députés d'être annulée et
d'être inéligible et de ne pas pouvoir
se représenter et de voir leurs comptes
de campagne non remboursés est-ce que
numéro deux déplacements seront onze
millions non un million plus d'un
million six de dépassement puisque le
compte avait été sous-estimée et donc le
dépassement est de 4% mais le compte
avait été sous-estimée de presque un
million 6 c'est à dire qu'il y avait eu
fraude fraude dans la déclaration fraude
dans l'utilisation des moyens de l'état
qui est un motif aussi d'annulation et
de réforme du compte quand on fait en
sorte de faire payer ses dépenses
électorales par l'état ce qui a été le
cas pour monsieur sarkozy dans une
partie de sa campagne et donc le
odeurs vient devant le bureau politique
est acclamé par tout le monde mais est
acclamé je trouve qu'il y avait là
quelque chose qui ressemble à de la
politique spectacle qui était tout
simplement indécent cette soirée là on
entendu la gauche a donc monté au
créneau après donc cette intervention
nicolas sarkozy mais par vos attaques ne
risquez-vous pas d'alimenter un peu plus
la théorie de l'acharnement est ce qu'il
ya une certaine fébrilité quand même à
gauche à l'idée d'un retour de l'île
connaisseur qu'il n'y a pas
d'acharnement mais dans le même temps il
faut dire les choses quand on est
acclamé alors que l'on a fraudé moi je
souhaite le dire et de la même façon
aujourd'hui jeudi que le temps de
nicolas sarkozy est plus un temps
judiciaire qu'un temps politique
il a à répondre à de nombreuses affaires
qu'ils le fassent et ensuite nous
verrons
moi je pense que le candidat qui sera
choisi par la droite car il y en aura un
le moment venu je ne sais pas le
processus qui le mettront en oeuvre je
ne sais pas qui sera ce candidat
je joue un peu difficile 16 pour leurs
primaires je ne sais pas mais je sais
pour l'avoir vécu que ce n'est jamais
facile que ce n'est jamais facile quand
on est dans l'opposition de désigner son
candidat et pour autant je pense que ce
n'est pas un ce qui passionne les
français aujourd'hui de ce qui est
important pour la gauche
quand nous irons devant les français en
2010 est le principal argument
ce sera la réussite ou non de notre
politique est pas le choix du candidat
qui sera le choix de la plage et
intérêts à un ump affaibli par des
difficultés financières ou est-ce qu'il
faut sauver ce soldat ump qui qui est
quand même le principal parti
d'opposition se refait pas ne vous en
faites pas pour la droite
s'il y avait eu il ya quelques années
une limitation des dépenses de campagne
c'est bien parce qu'il y avait une
inégalité qui s'étaient créés entre ceux
qui possèdent de l'argent dans ce pays
et qui aidait la droite et qui ont fait
que toutes les nouveautés toutes les
dépenses supplémentaires les affiches 4
par 3 les affiches en couleur sont
toujours arriver parce que la droite
avait beaucoup d'argent à consacrer un
temps j'allais aller danser vient cet
argent ce que vous savez il va revenir
ils ont beaucoup d'amis qui sont prêts
les délais dans ces moments difficiles
et je dis simplement aux français
ne vous laissez pas avoir ne vous
laissez pas avoir profité de votre
argent pour faire autre chose que de
donner au parti qui a fraudé et qui a
aujourd'hui assez d'amis pour pouvoir se
débrouiller il n'y a pas péril en la
démocratie
alors elles sont nées de sujet mardi
c'est la fin du député maire
le non cumul des mandats fait le carton
plein à l'assemblée nationale le projet
de loi interdisant à comps interdisant à
compter de 2017 un parlementaire
d'exercer une fonction exécutive locale
a été adopté à la majorité absolue ce
qui lui permettra de passer outre
l'opposition du sénat
les détails avec jean baptiste de glace
pour 300 contre 228
l'assemblée nationale a adopté le
gouvernement peut souffler il espérait
dépasser la barre des 2 189 voix pour
obtenir la majorité absolue avec 300
votes pour manuel valls eux peut aborder
l'obstacle du sénat
avec sérénité beaucoup pensaient qu'il y
aurait des déchets de certains
socialistes ne voterai pas c'est sans
doute le cas mais en atteignant les 300
voix ce premier texte en les dépassant
pour le second c'est une victoire
le ps a presque fait carton plein à
peine 10 abstentions et 4 votes contre
dans trois députés proches de
jean-pierre chevènement
de quoi décevoir ceux qui misaient sur
un sursaut des cumulards du ps ils sont
suffisamment faibles pour avoir compris
qu'ils ne pouvaient pas se séparer sur
ce texte
c'est ce qui a fait que globalement les
ans pratiquement tous
votez pour lui je crois que c'est
surtout ça mais l'opposition ne se
résignent pas l'examen au sénat sera un
bourbier pour le gouvernement en
espérant un retournement de situation à
l'assemblée en deuxième lecture
il suffit que six députés changent
d'avis pour que et bien la majorité ne
soit plus acquise puisqu'il faut 289
voix dans le cadre d'une loi organique
nous allons poursuivre le combat
dénoncer les pressions incroyables qui
ont été exercées sur un certain nombre
de députés socialistes et puis nous
allons continuer notre travail de
persuasion
le groupe ump avait envoyé une lettre
solennelle au député maire de gauche
pour les rappeler à la raison un travail
de persuasion qui n'a pas porté ses
fruits
dans ce sujet daniel fasquelle député
ump parle de pression incroyable exercée
sur les socialistes c'est vrai c'est un
engagement des socialistes depuis des
années qui a été un engagement voter
dans tous les congrès depuis près d'une
quinzaine d'années qui a été votée
encore très largement par les militants
et par une grande partie des élus il y a
deux ans et donc aucun des députés
socialistes ne pouvait s'attendre à ce
que nous ne mettrons pas en oeuvre ce
qui a été voté ce qui était connu et
c'est pour cela que ça a été très facile
pour moi absolue elle est exclue le fond
les députés vous les avez vraiment
convaincu il ya eu de l'action il ya eu
pression d'avoir des militants et des
français les militants ont voté flat une
immense majorité les français sont quand
on leur demande s'ils sont pour ou
contre le cumul des mandats ils sont
contre de façon très très massive et
donc la pression elle est d'abord venue
de nos concitoyens et ils ont raison
et ce n'est pas le dire à vos amis
sénateurs qui sont vent debout et je
leur jeu je leur dis qu'ils n'ont pas
intérêt à être vent debout que cela
appartient à la rénovation au
renouvellement de notre corps politique
de notre république de nos institutions
et qu'il est bien que les élus puissent
aller d'une responsabilité à une autre
je ne dis pas que l'on doit être
uniquement sénateurs ou députés jeudi
que l'on doit faciliter l'obtention des
mandats qui peuvent être différents mais
n'en exercer qu'un principal en même
temps et c'est quelque chose que nos
concitoyens peuvent comprendre que je
demande aux sénateurs de comprendre
aussi
répondant crash territoriale évidemment
comme toujours mais l'ancrage
territorial il existe par la nature même
de notre élection
les députés simplement député existe
aujourd'hui à l'assemblée nationale ils
sont réélus pour la plupart d'entre eux
pourquoi parce qu'ils tiennent des
permanences dans leur circonscription
parce qu'ils sont à l'écouté des maires
de leur circonscription et d'ailleurs
ils sont quelquefois des coudes entre
constitutionnellement à les
collectivités territoriales pour
représenter les collectivités et ne pas
être soi même le dirigeant d'une
collectivité il ya d'ailleurs tels que
sénateurs qui sont dans ce cas de figure
et posons-nous la question quand on a un
département quand on a une
circonscription et que l'on est maire
est ce que l'on écoute avec la même
attention les autres villes quand je
vois on y reviendra peut-être monsieur
carrese qui sur sa réserve parlementaire
donne est toute à sa ville tout à sa
ville et pas aux autres
je me dis que quand on est député maire
ou quand on est sénateur maire on a
quand même tendance à ne pas regarder
son territoire de la même façon vous
êtes sûr de votre deuxième lecture à
l'assemblée et ça se joue à une voix
près il y aura de 189 il y aura une
majorité qui sera encore plus large
parce que les députés socialistes qui
ont souhaité faire entendre une
différence en s'abstenant ou en ne
participant pas au vote sur la première
lecture ont conscience aujourd'hui que
le texte passera car il ya déjà la
majorité absolue émond pour la plupart
assuré de leur soutien sur la prochaine
lecture
juste un mot il fallait pas mettre ça en
place pour les élections municipales de
2014 que là on est un petit peu entre
deux élections on va élire un maire qui
sera plus forcément mère ensuite je leur
faisais le député je leur ai souhaité si
l'opposition avait accompagné ce projet
notamment en permettant aux suppléants
de rentrée à l'assemblée nationale si un
député faisait le choix de son mandat
local cela aurait été plus facile et
dans le même temps je vous le dis
clairement ça a été une position d'
équilibre pour trouver une majorité
qu'il soit une majorité claire
cette majorité des 300 pour faire
accepter le
il a fallu en même temps que chacun des
élus que chacun des élus puissent
s'organiser dans cette perspective de
non cumul et il est vrai que si c'était
appliqué en 2014 ce qui me semblait
logique quand on voit qu'une loi en 2013
il me semblait logique qu'elle ne
s'applique en 2014 et en même temps
l'application en 2014 était une
application inconnue au moment d'une loi
qui n'étaient pas connues au moment où
un qui est choisie les suppléants au
moment où se sont fait un certain nombre
de choix donc 2017 s'imposait pour
trouver une large majorité
et de toute façon ça s'appliquera à tout
le monde en 2010 est alors ce mardi
encore le bureau national du ps réuni
pour entériner un rapport interne sur
les retraites on reviendra tout à
l'heure sur les recommandations que fait
le parti
en tout cas les divisions se font sentir
dans la majorité puisque les le gauche
comme on l'appelle préconise un report
de la réforme qu'elle juge inopportune
rym ben ammar la réforme des retraites
mais le paie sous tension lors de son
bureau national le parti tente de se
mettre d'accord sur une seule et même
ligne pour la future réforme
peu de temps avant la gauche avait pris
les devants en adressant une lettre aux
responsables du parti demandant tout
simplement de reporter la réforme jugée
non urgentes et injuste en l'état le
rapport moreau a fait toute une série
propositions elles certaines d'entre
elles sont dangereuses
individuellement et cumulativement donc
je souhaite qu'on puisse avoir une
expression suffisamment fort pour dire
pas de baisse des pensions pas de
désindexation pas de baisse du pouvoir
d'achat des retraités
des propos qui évite certains
responsables socialistes
il demande à l'ailé gauche du ps de
serrer les rangs
j'ai qualifié cette gauche
l'ailé gauche du parti socialiste mais
qui va au delà de démissionnaires je
pense que quand j'entends un certain
nombre d'entre eux j'ai le sentiment que
ils ne veulent pas finalement assumé la
responsabilité du pouvoir parce que pour
eux gouverner c'est trahir
nécessairement ces critiques tombe très
mal pour le gouvernement il entame à
peine les négociations avec les
syndicats et le patronat elles vont
durer tout l'été les syndicats honteux
déjà annoncé un mouvement de grève pour
le 10 septembre le projet de loi sera
présenté à la rentrée à l'assemblée et
l'exécutif aura besoin de tous les
soutiens à gauche pour faire passer
cette réforme déjà très controversé on
suppose que vous allez dire la même
chose que christophe caresche à cette
aile gauche rentrait dans le rang
national s'est bien passé il n'y a eu
aucune opposition
c'était aux abstentions et avant voilà
et donc nous avons réussi à trouver un
accord au bureau national
et moi je dis toujours à cette gauche
faisant attention à ne pas être présent
dans l'esprit des français sur quelque
chose qui courent encore quelquefois sur
cette gauche qui aurait de bonnes idées
qui auraient des idées humanistes métier
en fin de compte ne serait jamais là
quand il ya des difficultés n'aurait
jamais le courage d'affronter celle-ci
et repousserait tout le temps les
grandes réformes et la nécessité à
prendre ses responsabilités
moi je suis aujourd'hui avec un mandat
clair donné par les français il ya un an
qui est de mettre en application le
programme du président de la république
en même temps de réformer notre pays et
de le faire différemment que l'aurait
fait la droite est ce que je dis à cette
aile gauche c'est oui il faut une
réforme des retraites et battons-nous
pour en faire une qui soit différente de
celle que nous avons connue on de
l'autre estime que c'est une crise
conjoncturelle ils sont à votre avis les
responsables dans leurs propos je
n'emploie j'essaye de l'employé ces
termes là mais en même temps ils passent
un mauvais message aux français car les
français le savent eux qui l'y a besoin
d'une réforme des retraites et que le
système si on le laisse aujourd'hui
dérivés il y a un jour un responsable
politique qui dira attendait ça ne
marche plus le système par répartition
n'en peut plus voilà il est plus en
équilibre il faut faire autre chose ce
fameux texte de la rue de solférino et
il n'y va pas trop dans le sens non plus
du gouvernement puisqu'il lille il
rejette finalement les principaux points
du rapport moreau sur lequel se base le
un moment non le gouvernement a demandé
un rapport qui éclaire toutes les
possibilités de réformes
pour autant je suis inspiré quand même
l'action du gouvernement est sûr qu'il
va assurer la surnommant mais qui visait
surtout à mettre pour les partenaires
sociaux toutes les hypothèses sur la
table
je vais vous faire une confidence ça ne
va peut-être vous étonner mais le texte
que nous avons abordé est adoptée au
bureau national du parti socialiste nous
l'avons vu ces terres quelques réunions
préparatoires avec le premier ministre
nous en avons discuté ce n'est pas le
gouvernement qui a écrit ce texte mais
en même temps c'était pas le parti
socialiste qui fait la réforme
concrètement quand le rapport d'ipad
désindexation pas de suppression de
l'abattement fiscal de 10 % c'est-à-dire
en gros garder le pouvoir d'achat des
retraités
tout ça a priori jean marc ayrault a
plutôt souscrit mais il y a les
déclarations de jean marc ayrault qui
est venu très tôt dans cette réforme des
retraites que je reprend aujourd'hui à
mon compte en vous disant que les
retraités qui sont aujourd'hui les
petits de retraite doivent être
absolument préserver de tout effort
nouveau indexation premières notamment
visé pour les plus aisés je pense qu'ils
doivent participer à l'effort qui sera
demandé à tous les français mais à
contribution des revenus du capital sur
une piste ça pourrait prendre quelle
forme ça regarde on y lit a aujourd'hui
des richesses qui sont créées
indépendamment du travail le travail est
aujourd'hui prise en compte dans les
cotisations que ce soient par les
employeurs que ce soit par les salariés
il y a aujourd'hui de la richesse qui
secret sans qu'il y ait de force de
travail par des mécanismes financiers
par des il faut regarder s'il y a une
piste possible et pour autant je pense
que nous ne nous épargnerons pas une
réflexion aussi sur la durée du travail
il faut avoir des choses en tête
l'espérance de vie ça représente très
concrètement le fait qu'aujourd'hui un
salarié travaille moins de temps dans sa
vie qu'il ne travaillait il ya 30 ans
comme pierre mauroy a fait passer la
retraite à 60 ans on travaille à peu
près aujourd'hui 70 mille heures sur une
vie de sexe en miller c'est 10%
pour vous donner une correspondance on
passe à peu près 15 % de sa vie devant
la télévision et donc la montre bien
qu'il ya un temps de travail qui s'est
raccourci non pas à cause du temps de
travail mais à cause d'eux
la hausse de l'espérance de vie et donc
il faut travailler un peu plus pour
correspondre à cela mais les limites de
la réforme elles sont posées dans ce
texte préservation des petites retraites
réforme qui s'appuie sur les inégalités
qui ont été faites aux femmes
parce qu'aujourd'hui elles ont été les
principales touchées de la réforme de
2010 et puis c'est le medef et les
syndicats sont d'accord puisque l'aîné
qui est importante dont on parle depuis
des années et qui est importante parce
que les inégalités face à la mort
suivant le travail que l'on a eus
pendant sa vie sont importantes encore
dans notre pays leroux mardi encore le
sénat donne du fil à retordre au
gouvernement le projet de loi sur la
transparence de la vie publique a été
renvoyé en commission et le vote sur ce
texte est loin d'être acquis au sénat
c'était pourtant la réponse du
gouvernement à la sphère cahuzac flora
sauvage d'emblée ça commence mal dans
l'hémicycle du sénat cet après-midi les
radicaux de gauche pourtant allié des
socialistes annoncent qu'ils ne voteront
pas le texte du gouvernement un ministre
un membre du gouvernement monsieur
cahuzac est mis en examen et l'exécutif
semble vouloir détourner l'attention en
tournant le projecteur vers les
parlementaires le projet ce n'est plus
seulement de la transparence mais du
voyeurisme matinée de jésuitisme face à
ce désaveu le gouvernement prend acte de
la décision des radicaux à l'ump on
dénonce un texte écrit dans la
précipitation et qui n'auraient pas
permis d'éviter la sphère cahuzac
le parlement n'a pas à recevoir
nécessairement des leçons de morale de
l'extérieur alors qu'il a en son sein
suffisamment de forces pour organiser sa
discipline c'est ma conviction vous le
dites monsieur longueur en entonnant la
vieille chanson qui berce l'inertie
politique que l'on va en faire trop et
qu'on va aller trop loin
c'est la vieille chanson parce que ce
sont toujours ceux qui se sont opposés
aux évolutions qui reproche ensuite à
ceux qui les provoquent de franchir une
étape trop importante
un peu plus tard dans la soirée coup de
théâtre le texte du gouvernement sur la
transparence dans la vie politique et
renvoyer en commission le scénar va
devoir revoir sa copie alors depuis on
sait que les sénateurs en commission
jeudi sont revenues à la version
initiale du gouvernement
ils ont émis l'idée de publier les
patrimoines des parlementaires audio est
ce que vous seriez prêt à voter cette
modification si elle arrive à
l'assemblée en tout cas je suis prêt à
prendre en compte comme étant une bonne
proposition c'était la proposition
initiale du gouvernement nous avons dans
ce total des patrimoines visible par
tous sans s'en aller à la préfecture
voilà moi je suis de toute façon sur
cette idée et c'est pour ça que je
trouve que le sénat a donné un mauvais
signe en début de semaine qu'il faut
aujourd'hui des actes forts qui
permettent de dire aux français ce
qu'ils prennent les responsabilités sont
des gens intègres sont des gens honnêtes
ils le savent mais il faut en donner des
preuves ne rien cacher et c'est pour
cela qu'il faut faire des déclarations
qu'elles soient vérifiées et ensuite
qu'elles soient consultables
moi je pense que plutôt qu'elles soient
consultables quelle fuite comme cela
dans la nature ce qui est le plus
protecteur c'est que ce soit l'état qui
en fait la publication au journal
officiel et que chacun puisse aller
consulter le journal officiel mais ce
n'était pas la position d' équilibre que
nous avions prouvé à l'assemblée
j'essaierai d'en rediscuter la semaine
dernière je trouve que le sénat a fait
somme toute en cette fin de semaine
du bon travail finalement le compromis
qui avait été trouvé à l'assemblée
nationale ce n'est pas une solution
suffisante pour vous si t'es pas
compromis moi je regarde toujours vous
parlez de l'autorité je regarde ce qui
me permet de rassembler tout le groupe
qu'elles soient consultables à la
préfecture par n'importe quel citoyen
sans qu'il y ait de sanction qu'ils
puissent être associés à cette
consultation ou qu'elle soit publiée au
journal officiel il y a deux solutions
moi aujourd'hui je pense que les deux
représentent une avancée et d'ailleurs
si on à l'inversion de vous avez aimé là
par contre ça ne pourra pas rester à
l'assemblée nationale moi je suis contre
que la possibilité que nous donnons à
des concitoyens de consulter puisse
donner lieu à des sanctions version
c'est pas forcément la version du groupe
socialiste c'est ce que j'essayerai de
défendre je pense qu'il faut des
sanctions quand il y a une volonté de
nuire
et donc quand on trafique ray les
informations que l'on va voir en
préfecture quand il y a la volonté de
désinformer de mal informés mais quand
quelqu'un fait état de ce qu'il a
consulté je ne vois pas comment on
pourrait le sanctionner
alors du coup l'examen de ce texte a été
reporté à vendre
10 à lundi cela bien sûr charges et un
calendrier législatif bien remplie
écoutez à ce propos jean pierre bel le
président du sénat ou bien vous en dis
que ce que nous regrettions c'est
peut-être un enchaînement trop rapide
des textes qui se succèdent le
changement mérite qu'ils soient
expliquées et en même temps mérite que
l'on soit pas dans une surenchère
permanente d'un texte derrière l'autre
de ce qui nuit à la lisibilité je crois
même de l'action gouvernementale
alors jean pierre bel en fait avait été
reçu à l'elysée à des jeunes et donc il
a émis ce conseil il a regretté auprès
de françois hollande et bien cette
surenchère législative est ce que vous
partagez ces propos bien sûr que nous
légiférons beaucoup et en même temps il
n'ya aucun texte qui soit ni mal
approprié ni anodin et nous sommes dans
la première année il y a beaucoup à
faire sur tous les terrains le terrain
de la tenue de nos engagements devant
les français mais le terrain de
l'urgence en matière économique le
terrain de l'urgence en matière d'emploi
donc quand j'entends ça je dis souvent à
ce parce que c'est vrai nos commissions
travaillent aujourd'hui à un rythme
absolument extraordinaire elles ont pris
du poids ces dernières années mais le
résultat est qu'au sénat ou à
l'assemblée la commission des lois pour
ne citer qu'elles
6 h 17 texte a examiné pendant une
session au siège mais sans désemparer si
elle se sent désemparé et pourtant
voudriez que je dise aux français on
n'en peut plus on va arrêter de
travailler devenu bien sûr que non tout
cela correspond à des urgences alors je
pense qu'il est bien d'attirer
l'attention du président de la
république sur la hiérarchie qu'il faut
peut-être encore plus posée sur la
préparation en amont qui doit se faire
de la programmation législatives encore
plus fortement mais pour l'instant je le
dis à ceux qui nous écoutent
nous avons fait dans cette première
année le travail qu'il nous avait
demandé est ce que finalement françois
hollande ne fait pas ce que vous
reprochez à nicolas sarkozy à savoir un
fait divers une loi la sphère cahuzac
une loi non non non parce que les faits
divers c'était souvent des faits divers
l'accumulation des loi en matière de
justice en matière de sécurité
cette idée que l'on pouvait avec la loi
règle est absolument tous les problèmes
et tous les faits divers sur lequel le
président de la république parlait et
des lois qui d'ailleurs la plupart du
temps été gommée par celle qui
arrivaient tout de suite derrière là il
y avait quelque chose qui a traumatisé
des français et qui portaient atteinte
je pense à tous ceux qui ont un mandat
puis
il ya tous ceux qui ont la fonction
d'exercer une parole au nom du peuple
français au nom de nos concitoyens et il
fallait leur donner des preuves il
fallait leur donner des gages et donc la
réponse du président de la république a
été une réponse rapide à la mesure du
traumatisme qui avait été celui d'un
ministre mentant à la représentation
nationale et donc aux français dans
l'hémicycle alors passer au mercredi et
aux ennuis judiciaires de bernard tapie
bernard tapie mis en examen pour
escroquerie en bande organisée se
réveille ce mercredi matin avec une bien
mauvaise nouvelle les juges en charge de
l'instruction ont procédé à la saisie de
certains de ses biens dont son immeuble
particulier de la rue des saints-pères
réaction immédiate de l'intéressé qui a
fait la tournée des télé chez marion
lefebvre c'est pas une part importante
c'est tout près de 280 millions d'euros
la justice a saisi une partie des biens
de bernard tapie bloqué ses comptes
bancaires
l'homme d'affaires s'estime victime
d'une exécution
on voit bien qu'ils se sont réunis les
juges le parquet alors qu'est ce qu'on
fait pour lui piquer ses biens est
effectivement pour arriver à me prendre
mais bien comme ils le sont il fallait
passer par une mise en examen de cette
facette d'un complot attendez qu'on vous
dit non non c'est ce que mon impression
voulait faire passer l'autre
interlocuteur pour un imbécile bernard
tapie refuse d'affirmer qu'il s'agit
d'un complot mais l'insinuent habilement
selon lui françois hollande n'est pas à
la manoeuvre mais il accuse les
socialistes et particulièrement le
ministre de l'économie
monsieur moscovici dit j'ai suggéré au
juge
j'ai suggéré au juge qu'on lui saisi
c'est bien pour que au cas où il serait
condamné on puisse les récupérer
je sais pas si non mais je ne sais pas
si vous mesurez quand le ministre des
finances dit j'ai suggéré au juge
car sam appel à vous rappeler une chose
simple
le procédé qui consiste à ce que l'état
se substitue une société commerciale
même si à lui appartient c'est un
détournement total
combative comme à son habitude bernard
tapie entend contester la saisie de ses
biens
deux assurances vie d'un montant de 45
millions d'euros les parts détenues par
l'homme d'affaires dans son hôtel
particulier parisien pour une valeur de
69 millions d'euros
sa villa de saint tropez ci compte
bancaire un contrat d'assurance-vie 280
millions d'euros et les parts de l'homme
d'affaires sur le groupe hersant média
face à la justice
bernard tapie a choisi la médiatisation
exposant son dossier au grand public
une façon aussi de répondre aux
multiples fuites qui entourent l'enquète
ou dans le rouge il a pas tord bernard
tapie quand il dit un ministre qui
suggère quelque chose à un juge comme ça
c'est une
c'est une violation de la séparation des
pouvoirs absolument pas du tout est
d'ailleurs tout cela a été démontré
ensuite par beaucoup de vos confrères
qui ont analysé ces propos l'état s'est
constituée partie civile et les
contribuables semble-t-il aurait pu être
floués d'un peu plus de 400 millions
d'euros ce n'est pas une petite somme
allés son travail et le juge mais bien
entendu mais quand il ya une partie
civile elle doit faire valoir ses
intérêts et en l'occurrence les intérêts
des français et donc il est normal
qu'une partie civile pour faire valoir
ses d'intérêt puisse suggérer que l'on
prenne des mesures conservatoires afin
qu'elle puisse être remboursée si jamais
il y as condamnation c'est ce qu'a fait
tout à fait normalement au nom de l'état
français pierre moscovici pour le reste
le juge est totalement indépendant sans
tarder saisir des biens pendant l
instruction
oui mais là le motif permet de le faire
escroquerie en bande organisée ce n'est
pas un petit motif quand même les juges
l'ont choisi nous ne leur avons pas
imposé ils doivent avoir une matière à
cela et donc laissons travailler la
justice il n'y a pas le moindre complot
mais vous savez à chaque fois que il y a
eu quelques problèmes à régler pour
monsieur tapie il y avait toujours cette
tentation de faire croire que la verve
qu'il a conservée d'ailleurs pouvait
faire en sorte de gommer et d'expliquer
par un complot ce qui se passait ce
n'est pas le cas que répondez-vous à
jean claude gaudin le sénateur maire ump
de marseille qui dit que c'est un
acharnement autour de bernard tapie et
bien il le doit à son soutien à nicolas
sarkozy pendant la dernière campagne
présidentielle où ce pas qui a soutenu
véritablement
un art tapis je pense que pour les
français ça n'a eu absolument aucune
incidence pour les français même moi je
ne regarde pas ce qu'ils ont soutenu
nicolas sarkozy ou un autre d'ailleurs
ce qui s'est passé avec monsieur cahuzac
où monsieur cahuzac avait soutenu le
président de la république pourtant il
n'a bénéficié d'aucune protection
il y a aujourd'hui que cela plaise ou
que ça ne plaise pas une justice qui
doit travailler de façon totalement
indépendante
quelle que soit la personne voir la
personnalité visée elle va passer au
jeudi et le gaz de schiste un sujet
toujours aussi explosive pour le
gouvernement
levée de boucliers contre arnaud
montebourg au moment où l'exécutif
souhaite tourner la page delphine batho
le ministre du redressement productif a
laissé entendre sa préférence pour le
gaz de schiste est cette fois un
recadrage est venue de matignon jérémy
hartmann après le limogeage de delphine
batho la semaine dernière arnaud
montebourg était prévenu aucun écart de
langage tolérée au sein du gouvernement
alors pour par les gaz de schiste devant
la commission des affaires économiques
mardi soir le ministre du redressement
productif a mis les formes
c'est une position tout à fait
personnelle qui n'engage pas le
gouvernement sait que nous puissions
avoir une compagnie publique et
nationale
exploitant les gaz de schiste et captant
la rente la partageant avec les
territoires
pour moi le problème ce n'est pas
fracturation hydraulique ou pas le
problème ces pollutions ou pas de poule
ce n'est pas la première fois qu arnaud
montebourg se positionne pour
l'exploitation du gaz de schiste
cette fois ci il va plus loin il en
précise les modalités
le jour même où le nouveau ministre de
l'écologie philippe martin pour sa
première intervention dans l'hémicycle
réaffirmé l'engagement du gouvernement
de ne pas fort et le sous sol français
jusqu'à la fin du quinquennat s'agissant
monsieur le député de l'exploitation des
gaz et des huiles de schiste par
fracturation hydraulique
le gouvernement restera ferme sur
l'application rigoureuse de la loi du 13
juillet 2011 qu'il interdit sur le sol
français
dans ce contexte la prise de position
d'arnaud montebourg apparaît comme une
nouvelle provocation aux yeux des
écologistes
à peine remis du psychodrame provoquée
par l'éviction de delphine batho du
gouvernement je ne sais pas à quel jeu
joue arnaud montebourg parler
d'exploitation propre des gaz de schiste
tout le monde sait qu'aujourd'hui ce
n'est pas possible je pense que c'est
une erreur au minimum une erreur de
communication
une erreur politique une gêne que
partage même certains socialistes au
juge partie de ceux qui pensent que se
rallumer ce débat n'est pas forcément
utile dans la mesure où de toute façon
c'est quelque chose qui échappe à la
vertu pendant encore de nombreuses
années quoi mais pour l'instant aucune
remontrance ni de françois hollande ni
de jean marc ayrault
visiblement plus tolérants avec arnaud
montebourg qu'avec delphine batho alors
finalement il ya eu des remontrances de
la part de jean marc ayrault en voyage
en roumanie jeudi le premier ministre a
redit son opposition à l'exploitation de
gaz de schiste quand même est-ce qu'on
n'a pas le sentiment qu'il ya deux poids
deux mesures vous vous dites est bien
arnaud montebourg a peut être parlé trop
vite mais il doit rester dans le
gouvernement quand on sait ce qui est
arrivé à delphine batho j'étais pas la
même chose delphine batho cela
concernait son budget la sphère n'est
pas petite elle n'est pas mince quand un
bus du un ministre dit mon budget est
mauvais et leurs eyjafjöll chose qui
n'était d'ailleurs pas vrai philippe
martin le démontrera dans les prochains
mois les prochaines semaines et dans les
prochains mois c'est un petit dossier
met les gaz de schiste des stars dossier
en tout cas prenons les choses de façon
assez simple il y a aujourd'hui dans
notre sous-sol en france des réserves
qui sont des réserves d'énergie des gaz
de schiste et des huiles de schiste
devrait-on ne plus en parler non il faut
en parler
peut-on aujourd'hui aller les chercher
non il n'existe qu'une technique est une
technique qui causent des dommages à
l'environnement par rapport au sous sol
et par rapport aux émanations
l'émanation de méthane est ce que cela
peut entraîner sur les nappes
phréatiques par une technique qui
s'appelle la facturation hydraulique et
donc les choses sont claires il ne peut
pas y avoir de constitution d'une
société car la technique aujourd'hui ne
permet pas l'explication
bondy faudrait encadrer quand même cette
recherche c'est bien gentil exploités je
vous le dis ce n'est pas la position du
gouvernement
et ce n'est pas nous at-il pas
démissionner si tu s'il ne donne pas la
position
ce n'est pas ne demandons pas devant une
commission des affaires économiques avec
une caméra qui filme et c'est très bien
vous même vous même vous prenez la
précaution au montage de votre sujet de
laisser la phrase ou arnaud montebourg
dit je m'exprime là à titre personnel et
il ya des sujets quand même s'il est
très personnel mais moi je pense qu'un
ministre doit être sur un sujet comme
celui ci dont on sait qu'il a des
incidences avec nos partenaires et je
les dis dans mes réactions je pense
qu'il faut éviter la provocation et en
même temps laissons aux ministres sous
la responsabilité d'une premier ministre
une marge de manoeuvre pour quelquefois
exprimer des idées faire en sorte de
faire avancer là en l'occurrence ce qui
fera avancer la question des gaz de
schiste ce n'est pas les déclarations
d'un ministre c'est le fait que demain
des industriels puissent nous proposer
une solution qui soit une solution
acceptable en matière qualité dit
françois breton est encore loin et on
est encore loin de ceux là et c'est bien
pour ça que je pense qu'ils viennent
bordure va-t-il montils au créneau sur
cette affaire villa provocation non je
peux j'ai dit qu'il y avait une part de
provocation dans ses propos parce qu'il
le cern haut et dans le même temps il
est il serait peut être provocateur il
en a le droit tout qu'arnaud montebourg
a le droit
savait il y a eu sur de multiples sujets
des prises de paroles des ministres qui
n'étaient pas des prises qui allait à
l'encontre des principes fondamentaux du
gouvernement sur le budget sur un
certain nombre de dossiers
moi je préférais tous les ministres
avant de faire des propositions les
voies avec le premier ministre avec le
président de la république et pour
autant j'ai considéré qu'il était normal
qu'il soit rappelé à l'ordre par le
premier ministre mais de ne pas en faire
plus sur cette affaire il n'y aura pas
d'exploitation des gaz de schiste en
france dans les prochaines années tant
qu'il n'y aura pas une technique qui
soit une technique qui après un large
débat public soit validé par nos
concitoyens enfin delphine batho aurait
sûrement aimé autant d'indulgence vers
certainement alors on va terminer avec
le bon vieux serpent de mer de la
réserve parlementaire
faut-il la supprimer ça pourrait être
une énième question du grand oral de
l'ena ce qui est nouveau c'est que
désormais l'attribution par les députés
des sommes qui leur sont dues
rc est disponible sur internet jean
baptiste daoulas depuis hier des grands
sites d'infos ont mis en ligne un moteur
de recherche
chaque subvention est indexé par
parlementaires et par ville avec à
chaque fois le montant versé
sans surprise les élus privilégient
souvent leur commune d'origine et leur
circonscription
au programme des aménagements de voirie
des rénovation d'églises ou encore des
constructions de bâtiments mais aussi
quelques curiosités
le sénateur ump serge dassault a financé
pour sa ville de corbeil essonnes la
moitié d'une tondeuse autoportée 200000
euros
la répartition de la réserve révèle
aussi des inégalités entre
parlementaires les présidents des
chambres sont les mieux lotis avec 12
millions d'euros distribués par le seul
bernard accoyer
depuis l'élection de jean pierre bel
écho bartolone les règles ont changé
désormais chaque parlementaire dispose
de la même réserve
environ 130 mille euros par an faut-il
aller plus loin et la supprimer
une question qui divise à l'assemblée ça
permettra aussi aux députés
sur le plan local d'avoir une certaine
action et sur ce point là je trouve ça
très cohérent avec le non cumul des
mandats
non il ya trop de fait du prince il ya
beaucoup de parlementaires qui utilise à
bon escient leurs réserves et qui donne
des coups de main à des gens qui ne
seraient pas aidé sans ce dispositif là
et puis à des gens qui en profite pour
apporter des financements à des
institutions qui peuvent en avoir par
ailleurs et donc il ne le mérite pas en
attendant une éventuelle réforme
on devrait connaître dans quelques mois
l'impact des nouvelles règles mises en
place par jean pierre bel et claude
bartolone
chaque année la réserve coûte environ 90
millions d'euros à l'assemblée nationale
et 60 millions au sénat ce qu'il faut la
garder il faut la supprimer cette
réserve 81 cents six ans plus de 100
millions presque 200 millions
ainsi qu'on a qui sont reversés vous
l'avez dit d'ailleurs les français y
voient à des associations ou à des
collectivités et d'eau qui sont utilisés
de façon productive c'est de réserve
parlementaire et pour autant mais là je
vais prendre la précaution qui avait
écrit arnaud montebourg tout à l'heure
je m'exprime à titre personnel ce n'est
pas la vie vous l'avez vu de tous les
députés que je pense qu'il ya là une
forme d'archaïsme je pense que le rôle
d'un député c'est de voter la loi ce
n'est pas de distribuer de l'argent
surtout que si la somme est en fin de
compte relativement limité comment faire
des choix
quand on est sur une circonscription
lyrisme illimitée très importante on
avait des poils et précis elle était
très importante moi c'est l'année 2011
dont il s'agit je crois que je n'ai rien
voire quatre je ne suis pas sur la liste
mais pour une raison simple c'est qu'il
y avait une totale opacité et puis que
quand on était dans l'opposition on nous
disait souvent maintenant vous n'aurez
rien il y avait ceux qui se servait et
il y avait ceux qui n'avaient rien moi
j'ai dû financer sur mon dernier mandat
pour une association d'enfants
handicapés
quelques équipements mais c'est tout et
je ne savais pas que je pouvais en faire
plus personne ne me dise avons
aujourd'hui au moins il y a une règle
qui est l'égalité entre tous les députés
et la transparence et pour autant je
pense que si l'on transférait dans les
prochaines années
ces moyens de la réserve parlementaire
vers les moyens d' expertise des députés
la capacité à travailler avec des
cabinets spécialisés sur les textes en
portant la capacité comme des parlements
dans les autres grandes démocraties moi
je rêve quand je discute avec mes
collègues des états unis quand je vois
les moyens d' expertise dont il dispose
je me dis qu'ils sont utilisés à bon
escient peut-être que cela pourrait être
une piste de réflexion on est à la
limite de l'achat de voix et notamment
au sénat les sénateurs sont élus par des
grands électeurs ça pose un problème
la distribution d'argent même si elle
est contrôlée et à les contrôler même si
elle est transparente et elle va
obligatoirement de venir avec ce
dispositif transparente quand elle est
associée à un mandat parlementaire me
semble un peu anachronique et c'est vrai
qu'il ya des critères qui prévalent dans
ses choix dont on peut se dire qu'ils
ont quand même très largement une
signification politique
mais c'est la fin de cette émission
merci d'avoir été avec toi merci
d'adresser jusqu'au bout parce qu'il
faudrait que la climatisation ne marche
pas qu il fait 40 degrés sur ce plateau
un petit avant goût d'été c'était la
dernière saison merci beaucoup d'avoir
été avec nous et bonnes vacances à tous
vous vous continuez continuez encore
croire le mans